the two hot beds right now are here and
there yeah those are two hot beds and
there's all this debate as to like which
one's better or whatever it's silly it's
that's a great hotbed yeah no denying
that there's some world-class comedians
over there and then there's ones that
show up there and here like Chappelle
he's always bounce bouncing back and
forth Chris Rock was always bouncing
back before Louie would news working in
here but Louie's working again he's
working at The Improv right now Louie CK
in San Jose yeah oh wow that's cool I
think he's gonna sell out a world tour
in like a year for sure for sure her
next month even if we wanted to yeah for
sure
you know I mean it's it's interesting
this whole bit about the parkland
shooting you know you know yeah so that
stirred up all this controversy that is
so that's such a louis c.k bit it's
interesting it's almost like people
don't understand what kind of comedy he
did right yes like suddenly they forget
who he was yeah if you look at his
comedy you're not even surprised that he
was jerking off you know kind of room
service sort of deal you know but he's
he's his style has always been like that
I mean that he's his style is always
very irreverent yeah saying [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you can't believe he's saying and
you know well written and well thought
out stuff this is stuff he's working on
and this is people like you know how
could he joke it wasn't even that good
he probably wrote it that day yeah two
days before who knows how many times
done that bit but I guarantee you the
guy takes ten months off his stand-up
and then he's starting to do it again
I don't he was scared of that I don't
think I would ever joke around about
that I definitely wouldn't joke around
about but you can yeah Nate I don't know
if I would it just wasn't it wasn't his
best stuff it wasn't good it's like it
wasn't ready yeah but maybe he could
have come up with a different turn on it
where wouldn't be is offensive and it
would be way funnier that's what working
on a bid is all about right like [ __ ]
look Holtzman Brian Holtzman if he had
said that exact same thing that Louis
said we would be Howlin yeah we'd be in
the back of the room slapping the table
Howell and laughing yeah cuz you put the
[ __ ] fat kid in the way
literally that's a bit that if Holtzman
said we would be crying we'd be slapping
the table we'd all gather around and
watch him write late-night Saturday an
issue right it wouldn't be an issue at
all because we know that it's humor is
it yeah it's a [ __ ] up thing to say
that's kind of the point the whole art
form is about saying things that are
funny sometimes saying things that are
funny or self-deprecating so sometimes
they're [ __ ] up yeah they're always
different
sometimes saying things is they're funny
is really adorable yeah someone will say
something it's real adorable but also
hilarious yeah
or your act this is odd odd and
hilarious just very very Theo von yeah
if I had to describe your act I'd say
it's very Theo von
really yeah that's you you know how to
do it but it's like everybody does it
different folks and you know you take a
set from someone who's just working
stuff out and you pretend that this is
done he's probably half those words he's
saying he's probably trying to be in the
moment he's probably got a place to go
kind of got some punchlines and hoping
that he'll see something in it while
he's doing it and working it out yes and
then you listen to the recording and you
go why did I say it that way why did I
do this and you change that and add this
and it's just to learn yeah and then you
know it just can't expect them all to be
good either like immediately especially
when the guy's been on trial like you
know or been you know under that social
pressure and or just like you know and
you know probably been dealing with
remorse and going to self hell I don't
know I mean who knows what he's been
doing this is my this is my take on a
lot of this and I think this is an
important thing to say we can't lose our
empathy we can't lose our compassion we
have we have we should be compassionate
towards victims we could we should be
compassionate towards each other we
should be this this tendency to want to
stop people from working and being like
there's a certain amount of time where
it passes and it starts to look like you
don't want anyone to have a path to
redemption right which is everyone's got
to have a path to it they have to
because we're all faulty yeah human but